welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of hawkeye
episode 3 echoes which beautifully
shifts perspective to echo maya lopez
now confirm to answer to a guy who
probably crushes heads and car doors
from hawkeye's trick arrows to the
clever camera work to the cryptic ways
they make us say uncle
there is so much to break down so let's
go back through this episode scene by
scene for everything you might have
missed the episode opens with young maya
lopez i assume age seven or so because
their writing workbooks say grade two
darnell bisa who plays young maya looks
significantly younger than the other
kids in her class which both makes us
feel her intimidation while also hinting
she's intellectually advanced for her
age 2007 is five years before the origin
story flashback we saw for kate bishop
and even before tony stark became iron
man in 2008 2009. this episode casts
maya as a parallel character to kate but
with greater challenges in her journey
as a similarly groomed child warrior and
by starting her path chronologically
earlier it casts maya as a kind of
soldier kate could turn into if she
sticks to the path her mom's set up for
her but it also makes maya a participant
in a chapter of mcu history well
underway before tony stark came out of
that cave as we also saw with shang
chi's backstory with the 10 rings the
camerawork takes us inside maya's point
of view as she reads her teacher's lips
at one point just showing the word words
but this girl is actually way ahead of
us she completed her worksheet where she
wrote games to play are solitaire and i
spy since she's often alone and has
advanced observational skills also she
wants to learn how to play capoeira
that's the brazilian martial arts style
showing this girl's ambition and when we
see adult maya fighting later on it
seems like she's pretty well versed in
it also she writes she runs as fast as a
dragon and she even drew a pretty solid
dragon on the worksheet that puts adult
kate bishop's doodles to shame speaking
of dragons maya shadow puppets as a
larger dragon head that eats the bird or
hawk a shadow cast by her father william
lopez played by the amazing character
actor zahn mclaren whom you might know
from his great roles in westworld and
fargo so many other things you'll notice
framed on her wall is a u.s karate
semi-finalist achievement award meaning
maya's already fairly accomplished at
this young age and they talk about
dragons
um no
maybe they are
but dragons
live in a different world
that
would
make them
stronger so this way maya ends up seeing
herself as a unique being who must
toggle between two worlds you could also
draw a connection to the great protector
and dweller in darkness from shang chi
both of which are powerful beings who
have to toe the line between worlds now
i still think kingpin is gonna be the
criminal element this series is leaning
toward but let's also keep our eye on
the den rings operation which again was
very active during these pre-ironman
years maya asks her dad
[Music]
i'm sorry
yeah it's implied that william might be
in some sudden financial trouble
connecting to his work with the
tracksuits and uncle it's just another
parallel to kate bishop whose father
similarly faced some mysterious
financial hardship followed by his
departure and instead the girl being
groomed by a more nefarious mentor and
you'll notice william has a chest tattoo
of triangles arranged in a sun pattern
later on as an adult echo gets that same
pattern stitched into her leather jacket
as a way to tribute him then at the
brooklyn karate academy one kid gets
thrown to the mat nothing in the scene
calls attention to this but the credits
of this episode list this kid as little
kazi meaning maya and qazi knew each
other as kids also a second track suit
exits the building well obviously their
boss is there so i think this school
might be a training ground for young
recruits of uncle's organization you can
actually see how that second track suit
is leading the instructor of this class
outside almost as if to have a chat
maybe about which kids are showing
promise the camerawork cleverly masks
maya's right foot behind her backpack to
make her prosthetic foot more of a
reveal then this fisky moment uncle will
take you home after class
i'll see you tonight
[Music]
yes it definitely seems like uncle is
gonna be revealed as wilson fisk kingpin
at least going by the fact that kingpin
is the boss of the tracksuits and of
maya lopez in the comics that the show
is based on also this shows references
to a head of organized crime and the
location of lot new york palace hotel
which in daredevil season 3 is the same
hotel that fisk buys also in this
episode fat man auto repair shop etc etc
but in this specific shot listen to the
sound mixing they give uncle's footsteps
heavier thuds compared to williams steps
[Music]
and he's wearing a tailored suit with
links which fisk in the netflix series
is famously proud of but more than
anything is his laugh
yeah if you watch law order criminal
intent you know this is dinaprio's laugh
also something he every once in a while
admits in an interview did you finally
get something to eat
we we wrapped okay
yes that breathy high-pitched chuckle it
just sounds to me like a possible
younger 2007 era wilson fisk so we got
to adult maya alaqua cox now in a boxing
gym i did look for signs whether this
could be fog wells gym of matt murdock
but i don't know if this is even in new
york because there's like an illinois
state champion sign back there but then
she pulls up to batman auto repair again
assuming trust a bro moving company is
an in-joke with tracksuits seems like a
front that they might have named in
honor of their own big boy kingpin boss
ronin slices his way through the
tracksuits a massacre shown in a long
take from the outside in just like his
slaughter in tokyo and in-game though we
must ask is this truly clint or could
clint have actually inherited the ronin
assassin title suit and sword from a
predecessor who actually is this one
here killing william lopez a predecessor
like jack dukane and that could be why
jack wanted the ronin sword so badly at
that auction jacques kane swordsman is
clint's past mentor in the comics and
this episode ends right before clint
turns to look at him we will see
but i could also see the series just
keeping clint as the killer of maya's
father just keep that juicy tension
between them you know whether we're
talking about characters like kingpin or
nick fury or the watcher there's no
shame in going bald if like you're on
the other side of it and you can own it
but when you're in that process of first
losing your hair and you're not ready
for that it can be very stressful for
the guys i know who are going through
that like it's not fun to lose your keys
or your marbles or just to lose anything
like your hair but if you've noticed
that has started to begin there is
something you can do to stop it because
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35 but with keeps it is
easier and more affordable to get
treatment for your hair loss and keep
the hair that you have keeps offers
generic versions of the only two fda
approved hair loss products out there
but at half the cost of your local
pharmacy though you never have to go
into a doctor's office with keeps you
get 24 7 access to a doctor who designs
the best plan for you they offer other
helpful tools and services including a
tracking tool so that you can monitor
your progress find out why keeps has
more 5 star reviews than any of its
competitors and nearly 100 000 men trust
keeps for their hair loss prevention
medication so if you're ready to take
action and prevent hair loss go to
keeps.com new rockstars or click the
link in the description to receive 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash new rockstars but maya now
finds her father mortally wounded
[Music]
as in fly away from this whole world of
crime don't let the violence consume you
and he presses his bloody hand to her
cheek leaving a handprint face marking
just like echo bears in the comics this
show
rules then episode title logo unlike
last episode features neither of the two
arrows hitting the target in the a as
this episode is less about kate and
clint the archers and more about maya
now the location of the tracksuit tied
out is an abandoned kmb toys warehouse
which in real life went bankrupt in 2009
and here in the post-apocalyptic mcu
there's no need for toys because
children turn into dust and others
turning to grown men who know play with
toys you see the track seats trust up
bro moving trucks parked out front which
actually if you think about it might be
a good cover for them always saying bro
we're just quoting our business nothing
suspicious but they also have this
tagline smile you're moving of course
these bros would tell people to smile
hey sweetheart i'm shoving their bed for
him down fire escaping singing the magic
dragons you should smile more
you talk
too much blah blah blah blah
maybe i
rip out your throat now remember it was
night before now it is morning meaning
the tracksuits must have spent several
hours toying with clint and kate on
those riding machines that played jingle
bells of course reminding clint of the
christmas with his family that he is
missing there are signs around this
warehouse for liquidation sale but one
behind clint reads nothing held back
kind of an odd choice of words for
everything must go actually there's a
similar poster later that underlines
this with when it's gone it's gone just
sounds like a pretty bleak sales push
for toys during the blip apocalypse when
things are gone they're gone kate gives
tomas advice for the imagine dragons
concert again with the dragons this
episode and maya noticing clint's
hearing aid cuts his hands free so that
he can sign
oh ah yeah sorry
hard of hearing not deaf
i love that they don't caption maya's
asl when showing her from clint's
perspective similar to how they
captioned her teacher with words earlier
also maya cutting his hands free so that
he could sign is ultimately what enables
clint to escape because then qazi has to
rush to rebind his hands behind his back
which is where clint can use friction to
cut himself free without them seeing
clint claims the ronin is dead so who
got him that
yeah clinton natasha romanov and he is
telling the version of the truth here
because he was on his violent path as
the ronin before natasha found him and
pulled him out of that life effectively
ending the ronin's murder spree after he
breaks free clint hides among the empty
toy stacks making this the second time
after loki episode 2 that mcu characters
on disney plus have hid from each other
in a disaster adjacent store setting
it's almost like these broken toys are
being re-shelved as merchandise to sell
disney plus subscriptions am i reading
too much into it clint pins maya to the
wall with two arrows and then mid-jump
he slices an arrow past kazzy's ear to
sever kate's tape notice how this arrow
and the other first few arrowheads are
field tips which are made for target
practice meaning that they're the least
lethal penetrating arrowhead just
showing how clint's objective here is to
kill as few people as possible all the
stunts and specificity of clint hitting
the tracksuits non-lethal zones like
their limbs their shoulders super
impressive especially clint's no look
shot through the guy's hand recalling
his no-look strike on a chatari in the
2012 avengers but i do have to give
credit to the background npc yeah yeah
you get that empty space now outside
kate wants to take the red challenger
which is a lot like the car they drive
in this chase sequence in the comics
it's based on but they subvert that
instead with this chrysler clint hot
wires it come on
[Applause]
yes more christmas music here the dance
of the sugar plum fairy which we hear
later in the episode
and then when they bump the car
the track changes to trip hack that's a
russian dance both of these songs from
the nutcracker composed by tchaikovsky
considered the most famous russian
composer this russian music scoring
their escape from the russian gang now
the amazing directors burton birdie
directed this episode and they feature
this one minute unedited rotating shot
in the back seat of the car which is a
direct homage to alfonso coron's famous
swivel shot during the car chase and
children of men one of my favorite shots
in all of film in that movie they
accomplished it by rigging a stunt car
with a hole cut out of the roof with a
camera hanging from the rigging above
which they may have also had to do here
at one point you'll notice the camera
switches to handheld as it moves out the
back seat window to follow kate outside
the car and you can see a lens flare
from the sun which might be where they
concealed a cut and we get to see all of
clint's trick arrows the first of which
is a putty arrow the next one's less
tricky it's really just a rpg if you
look closely in that car there is just
one guy in it the driver but yeah kate
bishop probably killed that dude next
she fires a plunger arrow which stays on
the windshield of that car right until
clint needs it at the end of the scene
and then this wire release arrow that
snares a bunch of christmas trees to the
truck you think of this in terms of
comedic heightening this is totally home
alone even with the tchaikovsky music
that john williams totally ripped off
for his score for home alone and the bad
guys are getting all sticky first and
then they get covered with christmas
decor there's a reason we love this then
clint fires a pymtech arrow at a normal
arrow that kate brings down resizing it
to be gigantic it's about not destroying
the suspension bridge of course
recalling clint and ant-man's teamwork
and civil war this arrowhead is stamped
with the pym logo so hank pym himself
must have engineered this and approved
it it glows blue the color of the pin
resizing disks when they are set to grow
mode like many of these goofy trick
arrows it just seems like all of pim
tech
spark tech was really designed to be
less lethal in general and perhaps hank
pym is now the chief armorer of this
faction of the avengers clint gives her
a usb arrow which we saw a version of
when clint fired an arrow with a
computer virus into the helicarrier in
the 2012 avengers we also saw the usb
arrow in the what if episode when they
downloaded the zola virus via arrow yet
when kate fires this arrow it just
bounces off ivan's chest i mean even a
usb tip with that momentum probably
should have impaled him a little bit
there's something about this guy like
when he broke the car window glass with
his bare fist i just think this dude has
been juicing on something then kate and
clint together leap off the bridge and
turn toward us recreating hawkeye's big
move that kate witnessed from the battle
of new york in the opening frame from
the fraction aha comics but here she
grabs the bow and they do this in tandem
swinging down this time sharing the
power move as co-equal hawkeyes which
clint verbalizes in the subway car oh we
gotta walk the dog i'm quite sure how
long a dog can call yourself one of the
world's greatest archers oh my god you
really think so i should walk your dog
they're cooped up all day yes they're
still not properly communicating and i
love the poster behind them for family
counseling framing these two as their
own kind of dysfunctional family unit
another rogers and musical billboard
appears tagline every avenger brought to
life which feels a little cruel both for
the dead of interests like natasha and
tony also for the ones who are still
alive like clint and then another
heartbreaking scene clint gets a call
from his son nathaniel to whom clint
says that he's gonna miss a christmas
movie marathon but that hopefully he'll
be their ugly sweaters so thinking about
this every day that goes by clint misses
another pitch that one of his kids said
at that dinner scene episode one nate
wanted to do gingerbread houses miss
that now he's missing lila's pitch of a
movie marathon and yeah he's probably
gonna miss cooper's day ugly sweaters
yeah even more depressing when you
consider that clint spent five years of
christmases without his family i'm like
ryan you're great kazzy tells maya
hmm so uncle didn't sanction their
hunting of ronan if it is kingpin it
would mean that he and the ronin have a
history and that he has specifically
spent these past couple years hiding
from the roman clint and kate wait in
chinatown beside a sign reading happy
new year 2020 something now there's a
set photo angle of this that showed it
was going to be 2025 that would have
placed hawkeye maybe in december 2024 or
since really the chinese new year would
be january 29th 2025 maybe this sign is
old and it's december 2025 i don't know
i've been burned trying to pin down
timeline logic before in the mcu and now
with hawkeye there's some marvel
producers who said this was two years
after end game which would put it like
in christmas 2025 but i don't know if
that producer is really thinking about
it like that i just think that confusion
is why they cover up the year now in
this shot and the diner kate says my dad
was
fearless
and his whole life was about helping
people ah was it i mean clearly kate has
some hero worship for her dad who
probably wasn't that great of a guy
another parallel to maya whose dad was
also working for a criminal network now
the directors place the camera directly
between the characters that force the
actors to stare directly into the lens
makes us feel a little awkward
uncomfortable wes anderson likes to use
this a lot jonathan demi used in silence
the lamps between clarice and hannibal
just as a way to force the actors to
feel that discomfort as they're acting
across from a machine instead of a
person helps underscore the awkwardness
here clint feels awkward as kate probes
about the ronin and him being a role
model and kate feels awkward that clint
is stonewalling her kate doodle's a
costume redesign with a huge h on the
forehead like hawkeye's look in the
comics hawkeye scoffs but his scar with
a bandage on his forehead does take the
shape of an h kate brainstorms names for
the dog using names of famous pizza
chains
dog father sir dog of pizza
pizza dog
clint talks about the tracksuit
organization they started small but grew
where's the guy at the top he'll do
anything to grow the operation
i thought maya was the boss no there's
someone above maya someone you don't
want to mess with yes this confirms that
clint knows uncle and he goes on to say
ronan hit the supplier on the other side
and then hit track certified management
yeah uncle's supplier might have
actually been that mexican cartel that
clint slaughtered that was mentioned by
rhodey in any game clint also wonders do
you think that the tracksuits were after
anything else at that auction it's
pretty upsetting to think there might be
stuff in the avengers compound floating
around out there yes reminding us of
that watch that the tracksuits did make
it their priority to steal i did think
for a second that ivan might have been
wearing it because he was wearing a gold
watch it is hard to tell but obviously
whoever really wanted this watch maybe
someone who values fancy finery and
cufflinks is really going to be the key
to unlocking this mystery eleanor's
penthouse we now see has actually been
reconstructed almost exactly from its
previous state before it was all
destroyed why rebuild it why is so
attached to this property well it might
be because my uh great great great great
grandfather built the building remember
at derrick's funeral we saw a headstone
for russell bishop implying that this
series is going to explore the bishop
family history and why they own this
property for over a century and why
eleanor seems reluctant to give it up
kate brings up listings from the bishop
security database on her mom's computer
qazi works for a company called sloane
limited night doubt is associated with
any of the random people names sloane
from the marvel comics is likely just a
shell company eleanor put on the books
to allow her to fund the track suits
operations discreetly it also says the
company was founded in 2011 right before
derek bishop's death just another clue
that eleanor might have had something in
the works before derek mysteriously died
off screen remember in episode one
armand told her
implying that our mind believed
eleanor's success was actually due to an
association with someone probably uncle
willy also on this list is the name kemp
m which could refer to michael kemp who
in daredevil season 3 was a riker's
inmate from whom matt murdock tried to
get information about wilson visk's
albanian connections and jack extends
the ronin sword right in front of
clint's neck from the right side of the
screen to the left across clint's neck
the same framing used to foreshadow
armon's death we think by this sword
during the auction episode one and we
cut to black before clint turns making
it still up in the air if plint and jack
might have had a past relationship and
that sword might have indeed previously
belonged to jack before it belonged to
clint one last detail that might be
nothing but i want to point it out
anyway during the closing credits the
cast names are all designed to have
extending arrows from the letters most
actors have both an up and a down arrow
in their name except four actors who
only have down arrows jeremy brenner
tony dalton frothy and vera farmiga
perhaps a clue pointing to which
characters might not make it out of this
series alive clint jack qazi eleanor
time will tell hey you can support this
channel by checking out our great merch
options at nrockstarsmerch.com follow me
on instagram and twitter at eavos follow
me rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis and breakdowns of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you